-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
Today is Valentine's Day,
so if you're watching
right now,
better luck next year.
[ Laughter ]
According to the latest numbers,
the average American
is expected to spend $200
this year on Valentine's Day.
Or $400, if you made her
breakfast in bed.
[ Light laughter ]
Eggs are super expensive
right now, guys.
[ Laughter ]
That's a joke about, uh,
egg-flation.
[ Light laughter ]
That's what Baze calls it.
In a video today announcing
she's running for president,
former U.N. ambassador
Nikki Haley said,
"I don't put up with bullies,
and when you kick back,
it hurts them more
if you're wearing heels."
Whoa, what job does she
think this is?
[ Laughter ]
Does she want to be president
or teach Krav Maga?
"When I fight
for the middle class,
I'll hold my keys so they
stick out between my fingers."
But she does make
an interesting point, though.
If she wins, she'd be
the first president
to wear heels since
the last president.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
A lawyer for President Trump
said recently
that Trump was using a manilla
folder marked "Classified"
to block a small light
on a landline phone
next to his bed.
Even weirder, all the ones
that he taped up to use
in place of curtains.
Buckingham Palace
yesterday announced
that Queen Camilla tested
positive for coronavirus.
Luckily, as a royal,
she was already planning on
doing nothing
for the next two weeks.
[ Laughter ]
The maker of the
robot vacuum cleaner Roomba
announced yesterday
that the company
would lay off roughly 7%
of its workforce.
And since it was Roomba,
it took everyone 45 minutes
to find the door.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, according to
a new analysis by Yelp,
the most romantic restaurant
in Wisconsin
is Grampa's Pizza.
That story again,
the only restaurant in Wisconsin
is Grampa's Pizza.
We got a great show
for you tonight.
That was a monologue.